A somewhat controversial legacy and
a lifetime spent in the public eye.
Jerry Springer might be gone,
but he won't soon be forgotten.
Jerry Springer was a TV icon for decades, best
known for his self-titled talk show that kicked
off in 1991. Springer himself would admit the
show changed pop culture for better and worse,
ushering in other shows of its
ilk that could affectionately
be referred to as "trash TV." The
show was synonymous with the 1990s,
but some may be surprised to learn it
aired new episodes all the way until 2018.
But even when the show ended, Springer didn't
leave television. He had another show lined up
called "Judge Jerry," where he took on legal cases
and ran for three seasons. In March 2022, the
TV personality spoke about how his other series
just didn't hit the same way as "Jerry Springer,"
and COVID-19 and its social distancing policies
didn't help matters. He told The New York Post,
"I was talking to parties that were
thousands of miles away — wherever
the suits were filed was where we put
the cameras — and you've got that delay,
no audience and [me] sitting in front of a
green screen. It wasn't what I first imagined."
But there was another issue Springer found himself
up against trying to make "Judge Jerry" work.
With so many episodes of "Jerry
Springer" produced over the decades,
it isn't hard to still catch an episode if you
have cable. Reruns still air on syndication,
which likely netted Springer a nice paycheck
of residuals every so often but also hampered
his efforts to expand into other series. COVID
played a role in the demise of "Judge Jerry,"
but he was also his own worst enemy, as
he went on to tell The New York Post,
"In most markets they still run 'The Jerry
Springer Show,' that's been holding on,
and there's only so much of me that a normal
human being can take. It was a containment issue;
if I was going to be so crazy on that show,
how can I suddenly be serious on the bench?"
"Okay, I'm putting like health, happiness, peace,
and prosperity in the room
so you can all feel that."
There's only so much Jerry Springer one
can take, and when it came time to end
"Judge Jerry," Springer fully understood
why it had to happen. He continued to say,
"I enjoyed doing ['Judge Jerry'], no question,
but the industry isn't based on, 'Gee, are you
having fun doing it?' It wasn't making the money
it was making in the beginning. I totally get it."
The success of one show doesn't
necessarily translate to another,
so in 2022, the show was
canceled after three seasons.
When The New York Post interview was
conducted in 2022, Jerry Springer was
obviously looking back on his life and
figuring out what it all meant. You could
spend a long time debating the merits of his
show and what it did for the culture at large,
but for Jerry, his hit series wasn't even
his biggest accomplishment. He elaborated,
"The greatest job I ever had was being mayor
of Cincinnati, and if God came to me and said,
'You can do one thing and you can do it for
your lifetime,' I would have chosen that."
Legacy is a complex question, especially when
it comes to public figures. Even Springer
admitted that most people aren't remembered
a couple of decades after they pass away, but
that really wasn't what he was angling for.
He just wanted to be there for his family:
"The important thing is to be remembered by
your kids and your grandkids. If they love me
and remember me and I've been a good role
model for them, that's all that matters."
Even though "Judge Jerry" ended sooner
than Springer probably would've liked,
his legacy in the realm of television is
secure. Jerry Springer died in April 2023,
but as he put it himself, his legacy will remain:
"As long as the crazy show keeps going,
I'll be a part of the fabric of
the memories of our culture."